et
[Musique]
en live en direct des états unis aux
chaînés rocancourt le centre commercial
westfield a vu se produire lady gaga la
star américaine dévoilée en avant
première leurs forces elles son nouvel
album ce live ce soir diffusé à wasyl
parly ii est un événement vraiment
unique puisque c'est un événement
hybride qui allie à la fois en fait le
digital et l'expérience physique hills a
effectivement cessé dans la lignée de la
stratégie de notre groupe de vouloir en
fait toujours répondre aux attentes de
nos clients qui veulent aujourd'hui des
expériences sensorielles émotionnelle
une plateforme digitale sur laquelle on
réunit en fait ce soir et c'est ce qui
est extraordinaire les fans de lady gaga
et en même temps nos clients nos
visiteurs de nos centres qui sont des
réelles destinations dans le monde 21
centres du groupe dans 10 pays
différents dont deux dans les yvelines a
parlé de la jauge permettait
d'accueillir jusqu'à 500 personnes
un concert pour découvrir la deuxième
collaboration entre lady gaga et tony
bennett n'a vu l'opportunité de venir du
coup
s'était vainement et on a sauté sur
l'occasion parce qu'on n'était jamais
bien un événement comme ça je suis là
parce que j'aime lady gaga parce que je
les découvertes d'enjeux star is born et
depuis j'ai aussi beaucoup c'est une
occasion de se détendre après à des mois
pour piquer vous savez bien
la soirée était aussi l'occasion d'un
appel au fonds pour les deux
associations des artistes
l'album est disponible depuis ce 1er
octobre
[Musique]